on n'a jamais mangé autant de salades
elles sont partout et y en a pour tous
les goûts sympa il ya beaucoup de
couleurs fruits
y'a des noix dedans mais moi j'aime ça
quand c'est un peu de croquant
nous sommes dans l' usine belge trop
haché rindt l'usaid est ouverte sept
jours sur sept
environ 365 jours par année ici on
emballe un rythme fou des milliers de
salades individuel se reconnaît dans les
premiers au canada c'est évident il ya
toujours une augmentation d'année en
année qui est de vertus de marché pour
cette spécialiste en marketing la santé
fait vendre on a des rythmes de vie
surtout dans les zones très urbaine sont
assez occupés et nomade donc il faut
trouver les solutions pour arriver à se
nourrir à des à des endroits publics où
on va avoir au moins la perception que
ça va être santé nous avons acheté les
salades les plus vendus en épicerie pour
savoir ce qu'elles valent et s'ils
peuvent servir de repas complet ça varie
beaucoup la savoie de la salade les
dessus un repos complet que des gens
vont acheter sens en pensant que c'est
un rappeur
je pourrais très bien moi même rajouté
une source de protéines des morceaux de
poulet veilleux à la coque un peu de
fromage mais en soi parce que c'est
halal annonce possiblement protéines et
en fait c'est le cas de plusieurs salam
qui ont pas vraiment produire en
épicerie il y a deux catégories de
salades celles qui sont préparés par des
traiteurs au jour le jour et celle
préparée en usines qui doivent
rencontrer des normes plus sévères et
visent des durées de vie prolongée
nous avons demandé à cinq consommateurs
de goûter à une sélection de salades à
des prix variant de 4 $ 50 à 13 dollars
la portion d'abord celles assemblées en
usine
4 dollars 50 pour celles à côté oui
c'est vraiment pas cher et légumes ça
coûte un peu moins cher peut-être mais
ayant racheté du poulet savons que tu
dis qu'à dollars 50 quand même une
protéine celle ci par exemple compter
ses hommes entretiennent la couche est
en fait à peu près 15 g de protéines et
plus pour avoir un repas complet donc
celle ci à 2 g de protéines nié se
conforme mais quand je regarde plus loin
d'avoir un truc tbs concepteurs comme un
mille 20 mg de sodium ce qui est énorme
et qantas dans cette petite portion sus
lambin exactement et 22 embellie paix
dont 6 g de gras saturés
la salade attitude donne même la
fourchette dans l'emballage la
vinaigrette et dans un conte dans le
plastique dans un autre compte en
plastique je trouve que c'est sur
emballages et les quantités sont très
petit il ya comme catenoy pin encore de
pommes pour beaucoup de verdure raconté
vraiment pas un choix que je ferai à
l'ellipse ils peuvent le prendre comme
repos mais on a toujours un peu
nous notre sort commun accompagne mais
on travaille en sorte augmenter le
niveau de protéine à l'intérieur des
consommateurs nous ont dit pourquoi la
vinaigrette qui est en bas les airs et
emballé dans un compartiment
c'est un contrôle vis-à-vis dans
l'emballage a dans l'usiné c'est le
contrôle des allergènes donc des règles
à suivre aussi protéger la valeur
nutritionnelle mais aussi la salubrité
de l'événement c'est sûr que l'industrie
fait des efforts pour améliorer les
emballages
mais il ya des questions de recherche
qui doivent se faire pour assurer la
salubrité et
ça prend un certain temps donc on peut
pas trouver une solution instantanée
ça se fait rêver passons salades
préparées au jour le jour
puisqu'ils sont souvent qui valait sur
place les marchands ne sont pas tenus
d'afficher des valeurs nutritives
donc on peut même peuvent valider c'est
vraiment j'ai les quinzièmes de protéger
dans ses collègues faut vraiment
retombée dans la liste des ingrédients
et l'idéal c'est de trouver dans les
premiers ingrédients les sources de
protéines un tempo le tofu par exemple
et non les pois chiches et compagnie
donc par exemple dans les eaux ving
c'est un peu le coeur ou au premier
ingrédient c'est un mélange de grains et
le timbre est donc fait je suis quand
même rassuré je devrais sûrement
amortissement de protéines avec soeur
contrairement à celle ci de même 10 ou
les sources de protéines en yvelines en
est grisant c'est beaucoup des légumes
c'est bien je vous des légumes mais je
doute que j'estime d'un manque de
protéines dans cet état là
malheureusement celle là et coûte 13
dollars vous pensez en pensez quoi
je trouve que la convention du fromage
avec le quinoa il en soit ça c'est
incroyable la vinaigrette est souvent
l'un des critères d'achat des
consommateurs
la vinaigrette c'est vraiment important
c'est ce qui donne du goût qui est celle
d'avril c'est juste de l'huile puis ils
citeront si je vais payer beaucoup pour
une salade je veux que la vie n'y fait
c'est pas quelque chose que je peux
faire à la maison
y'a des légumineuses de derrière des
pois chiche mais pas autant que ça on
peut pas vraiment les voir
en fait elle est très décevant de la
whey trois salades sont sortis du lot
aux vivres pouces menu et crudessence
j'aime beaucoup la vie
un vinaigre été très bonne tout comme
une salade de chou crémeuse mais est
végétalienne aux vivres à cause du prix
200 veaux c'est vraiment incroyable
la crue des 100 sites et à 8 dollars 50
oh vraiment intéressant la gamme de
produits crudessence a beaucoup moins
plus loin notre nutritionniste et à la
défense oppressant grâce au site va
enlever un programme en eux-mêmes et une
l'avoir vécu ou qui en fait qui
accueille plus de 50 g de lipides dans
une portion ce qui est énorme le propos
un repas pour une fallait quand même
vraiment beaucoup moi mais j'étais
vraiment surprise en voyant ces et même
chose avec les quantités de sel
il y en a une je pense que c'est la
grecque plus de 1300 les migraines le
stadium on a les pouces menu ici on peut
sony qui était quand même intéressante
au niveau du sodium jaune la texture des
micros pause si un petit peu de deux
showrooms marine et ça donne une
certaine assisté il ya du croquant que
je rajoutais c'était comme du grand hall
à est ce que il ya des produits qui se
démarquent clairement clairement un
bonne technique très belles découvertes
c'est ça la concerne 6 am en protéines
donc un fait d'un gramme de protéine par
torsion et qui sont très faibles en
sodium
ok je vais toujours recommandé aux gens
de faire leur chose de plus en plus à la
maison on met ces postulants non plus de
tomber deux ingrédients le donc ses
devoirs qu'est ce que j'aime us que
j'aime mieux prendre le temps justement
de l'assemblée ça dans vos têtes mer var
active ou acheter la paix que je suis
comme casser la tête
vous avez des sujets nous proposer des
situations a dénoncé écrivez nous à
radio trait d'union canada.ca barres
obliques l'épicerie